there are a lot of different C plus plus
libraries out there and I'm going to
make a video this video that kind of
explains what they are and how to start
creating your own so that's pretty much
it so what is the c plus Library it's
basically code that you can bring into
your projects just think of it that way
it's just pre-built stuff libraries
and if you want to build your own well
why would you do that basically for
portability if it's something you want
to reuse or you think other people could
find useful or it could be used across a
lot of different applications so now if
it's you know not super specific that's
that's why so you know just do a Google
search for C plus plus libraries and we
can look at some of these top ones and
what they do Poco is some kind of
networking Library
so it just basically helps you do server
Transmissions uh asio is a similar thing
opencv I don't remember tensorflow is
all about AI learning stuff eigen I'm
not sure live sound file this helps you
open binary sound files like waves and
stuff so a lot of these programs just
interact with your operating system you
know they're designed to spin up certain
things like your network or your
something when this live sound one just
knows how to unpack files basically of
certain types and help you load them to
playback so
you know it's all kind of generic stuff
that would be used over and over across
applications
all right so let's walk through how to
build one of these because that's the
main thing here to take away from this
build this uh video is just how to
actually do this and let's make it
really simple
so first we're going to launch Visual
Studio I'm using visual studio 2022.
you could be using a different one if
you want that's fine
but this version is uh the latest as of
the recording of this video
so let's go ahead and open this and in
this interface
when you open it for the first time you
should have it getting started well you
can create a new project continue
without code let's go ahead and create a
new project this is basically just going
to give us a little bit of boiler plate
that they add in which is fine we can
figure it out from here
we're going to do a cmake project a
cmake project is very portable it's the
great thing about it there are a lot of
Frameworks you can build around
and stuff like that and that's up to you
if you want to do that but I'm just
talking straight C plus plus and cmake
basically just helps sort out your
compiling commands and uh you know how
normally when you compile with C plus
plus maybe you know maybe you don't but
usually there's a long console command
of all the options cmake basically helps
parse that and it's very useful
I happen to have a lot of videos on it
um
MFC app is
basically a Microsoft Foundation class
this is very just Microsoft specific no
we could spin this up on our own if we
wanted to that just a different
boilerplate so
let's just do plain C make for this and
we're going to make a
somewhat of a nutrition app
um we're just going to kind of track
nutrition with this set for with this
Library so it's just going to be kind of
a thing you could bring in if you want
nutritional tracking in theory so that's
that's the point of this it doesn't you
know a lot of libraries are more
specific to Hardware coding things but
there's also ones for just supporting
other stuff so
and you'll find a lot of libraries made
for the Sciences in general
what do we call this nutrition app
almost what would not app
that actually has a
interesting ring to it nutrition app
I'm just going to call it plain old
nutrition and I googled it so I know I
spelled it right okay
so your interface should look the same
if you're choosing the same options
otherwise sort out has required I'm
gonna
go with place the solution and project
in the same directory that's just the
way it structures cmake we could always
change that later
just a few add subdirectory things in a
project top level
so we'll go to the solution Explorer
when you get this page
yours might look different you can sort
out some of your stuff by going to
window and showing windows and stuff
like that
but you should have a solution Explorer
somewhere and to start we're going to
change this to all files so let's just
make sure we have that set we're going
to click up here it's a little button
switch between solution and available
views and there is a folder View and a
cmake targets view so cmake targets view
specifically shows what cmake is
pointing to so it's a bit of a different
setup but it allows you to build stuff
individually
and hierarchies so that's kind of cool
and if we go to it we see we got
nutritional app there all right well
let's go back to the file structure
though so we'll click it again folder
view all right so it gives us
basically a cmake some presets don't
worry about those nutrition dot h and
not CPP if we look at these we'll see
that it is a main this is not a library
so let's change it to a library well
first of all we don't have a main F4
library because we're basically just
chunks of code that can be added in so
let's have an e function and let's take
in a struct called on
nutritional values and we'll fill this
out as we go and probably move it to
another file but we want things like a
float value called calories so let's say
that we just you know as the main take
in for this Library we're going to eat
nutritional values or food whatever you
want to call it we're calling it
nutritional values we're going to take
this as a const reference and then we'll
just call it value so what does it do
with it so this is where our library
would begin its process of doing
something we can sort that out a little
later for now let's go ahead and go to
the header get rid of the Scio stream
actually uh we can just get rid of
this entire thing for the most part but
we do want to forward declare our
functions and stuff
so
that way whoever uses this app knows how
to fill out nutritional values for
example
we can get rid of this namespace
standard too but uh yeah let's go ahead
and do that so I'm just going to move
this into its own file
and just put it in here
and so you do have to decide what
happens here we probably want some kind
of
set to create of all the things we've
eaten and add them all together or
something like that or maybe have days
or a reset button I like the idea of
having
just kind of a total list of everything
and a reset button I think that works to
start so let's do that so let's make
another struct which is called uh
nutritional totals and this is going to
hold a vector of nutritional values so
that way we're going to save everything
into this so that we can calculate it on
the fly or parse it but that'll be for a
later date
don't necessarily need to save this data
unless you're planning on accessing it
and playing around with it more later
but uh
that's up to you it's going to cause
some copying but it's not a big deal
here
most likely copying depends by how
you're doing it so maybe
uh yeah that's all we'll do so we'll
just add to that now this thing doesn't
know what a vector is because it's part
of a template Library it is basically a
dynamic array so just think of it as
that there's more to it obviously but
that's how we're going to use it for now
because well the thing is we want it to
be dynamic so we don't know how many
things you're going to pass in
necessarily it's not a specific number
and now what we could do is we could
just instantiate something here like
well we don't have any classes or
anything we haven't really gotten to
that so let's not worry about it um this
is a library it's got its own space when
you run so what if we just declare uh
like
current run
values which is just these new
nutritionals Total current run values
and let's have like a helper function
that just resets it or we could say like
new day let's switch to new day and all
that it's going to do is just reset this
so how do we reset it well currently
it's just going to be a list of values
so we would just get rid of them all
um
we could do that by calling the
values.clear now why does that work
because well
this is just a vector of nutritional
values and when you clear it
you remove everything from the list now
this is kind of packed into another
struct which might seem a little bit
weird but the thing is we're going to
have things alongside this at some point
and things that support it this might
make more sense as a class later but for
now everything being public is fine
because we are in the very
structural development no need to over
complicate anything just yet
in theory okay so what do you do when
you eat we got to fill this out and I
think we are probably where we want to
be
well whatever value comes in we can just
push it back to this and it's going to
do a pushback now this is a const
reference so what should happen here is
it should force it to copy basically so
it's going to copy this value in
and that is probably what we want in our
case it sounds slow but the thing is
we're kind of hard saving everything
dynamically so we kind of want our own
copy of it but that means the client
could then toss their data if they
wanted after they passed it in because
we have a copy of it hopefully that
makes sense but that's kind of important
to think about when you're designing
things okay so I think we're actually
good here let's just make one more
function though nutritional totals we
want to just let's just get like
get total calories or something just
some helper functions and all this is
going to do is return basically all the
values
foreign
all their calorie totals so we gotta go
through each of these and just add up a
total so I guess I don't know we'll do
that however we feel like if we could
just type it in here or we could put it
in a Lambda another way we could do this
is with the accumulate from numeric uh
we basically can use this function and
give it iterators and give it an init
value but this isn't quite right yet we
also need to do another thing we need to
overload the plus operator because this
is attempting to use the plus Operator
by default and that doesn't exactly work
unless we set it up for this because it
doesn't know how to plus to nutritional
values but we can tell it basically we
want to just do the calories of each and
sure we could do this all manually in
our own for Loop and maybe that's more
simple but the thing is maybe this plus
operation will come in handy later and
in that way when we need to edit code
later to update this we basically just
update the operator and have all this
code like over here can stay the same so
let's do that I'm trying to think off
the top of my head how to do this
um
and give it a quick yes and then I'm
going to Google it I guess we want two
different types of these we want a
nutritionals values one which might
belong somewhere else like in this
header alongside it
and we've got to make sure we get in
these paths in left-hand side and right
hand side I guess we just edit the left
hand side yeah
I think we could actually can we return
void here I forget okay well I'll look
that up in a second I'll actually do it
now
okay I guess it depends how we're doing
the function if we're doing it inside a
class it's different so if we put it
into here
there we go
so then what it would do is this not
calories
which is the one
it's operating on and we're just adding
this right hand side so we just do a
plus equals here
make sure we're getting the calories out
of the right hand side so basically any
of these values we just need to have
them all populated
so as we add more we'll do that
we'll add one more
and the value we're going to add is salt
and we want to just make sure to add
these as well so hopefully you can see
how to extrapolate here you can add as
many as you want
but this will come back to this a lot
because if we want to change or add or
remove we just do it in one spot and all
the front end stuff like this accumulate
should just work uh I think I gotta
figure out one more thing on this
accumulate I don't use it too often it's
actually kind of new
but you can do all sorts of cool tricks
with it okay well on further inspection
I might be over engineering this so I
think what I'm going to do is sure we'll
leave this plus equals code that might
come in handy but we're just not going
to use accumulate yet because I think
it's going to type and return another
value and yeah I'd have to do it
differently than I'm currently working
up so when we call this we'll just we'll
just kind of hard code it so that should
take care of it we just want to be sure
to initialize okay so this is looking
good now what we must keep in mind is
that the
this side of things we're actually going
to make that
um going to see me there's a reason for
it later
um you know we'll actually just remove
it uh sorry for the patrol now we might
actually just put it back later so if
you have in your code you can comment it
out or whatever it's fine but the thing
is
I think uh if we do it out of scope of
the class then we have to take in let me
see if I can just correct this real
quick
but uh yeah I'll get back to the main
thing shortly I think you just do it
like that you add it to the left hand
side
or do we return a new one okay I think
this will actually work this seems
really weird though maybe I should just
declare a new one now these ways might
all have their advantages these
different ways I'm kind of going about
put all also handled memory the exact
same depending on your compiler due to
optimizations so I think this is the
most proper way to do it though and we
can take this one in its constants a
little bit of a heavier version but it's
safer I think okay so uh yeah
point I wanted to get to very quickly
here was how to actually expose stuff
properly okay so from the end user the
person who wants to run this and do the
new day e thing those need to be public
those functions need to be accessible
to the user
so we just need to forward declare them
no need to Define them yet you just need
to say hey these are callable but the
code
of what they actually do is going to be
hidden
kind of an important distinction
that we might get into a little more
so this header is kind of working like a
public header
and this is kind of working like a
private file because it's going to be
hidden behind a library when a library
is built it is just binary code and you
don't need this CBP anymore you have the
binary code already ready and you just
link it to the rest of your code so this
is
um not going to just run on its own it
doesn't have a main let's go to the
cmake where it says add executable let's
change this to add Library we can leave
it all default it's going to build a
static Library by default
and that's all it takes now there's
nothing to run here but we can go to
build and build all
and we can still build the library but
to run it we need a sub project so let's
make a folder we'll call it tests and
we're just going to add another cmake
file in here and then this cmake well
let's uh yeah enable testing here on the
top level one
and then add subdirectory of the test
folder
and now we can fill out this test one so
that's all you need to do on the top
level this one we essentially want to do
the same thing let's go like so and
we're just going to add some executables
computables are like the little clients
we'll just call it tester to start and
we're going to feed it in on main.cp we
got to make a main.cpp standard C plus
plus
stuff that you learn right off make an
event May return zero
now let's go ahead and Link this to our
library our library is built earlier and
the project so this nodes knows about it
we can just go Target
link libraries
Target is our tester and the library we
want to link is exactly how it is
spelled here attrition
and then we want to add a test we give
this test a name
um
which is called demo
and we can give it a command
so the command here is just going to be
tester it's basically got to be an
executable
and then you can follow it with any
arguments if you want we're not going to
follow it with any arguments
um maybe we'll call this oh yeah we also
want to name space these a little bit so
let's just call this
um we'll put it in the namespace
nutrition commands eat so we're going to
in theory test the eat command here so
we could pass it something but I don't
know that's that's fine enough but
basically you want those dots there
because the test Explorer in Visual
Studio picks them up that way let's have
a look here
so bring up your test Explorer you might
need to go to like uh window or test
test Explorer
but I'll just get everything to build
and it should show up in your available
tests if it does not check your output
and error list we have some cmake errors
basically this Library needs to be
private or public let's make it private
and let's see if we can get it
okay one way you can be sure to check
all your builds is just change this view
to see make targets View and see if you
see everything under your project we
have the static Library it shows here
and we have the tester it shows here
and uh this should work but seem to be
having a few issues here
um you know the way cmake kind of wants
to be designed is the project is top
level and then everything underneath is
uh like your app right like this should
be there could be a whole conglomerate
of different libraries and executables
under a cmake project
so keep that in mind that is uh
something not everyone realizes but
that's not how we have it currently
designed so we put the uh we put the
main static library in the top level
which you know if that's how you're
gonna stick with it that's fine but uh
just be aware of stuff like that I think
we're all good here though because we
can build this one
nothing to do and build this one nothing
to do okay so this test should work then
we should be able to see it in our test
Explorer and there it is test Explorer
finally shows it and these drop downs
um are a little weird okay I guess this
top level one is the project and then I
named this namespace the same thing and
then the class commands and then eat
yeah that's just kind of otherwise it'll
just say undefined in these if you don't
do this so we can just run this one and
uh no matter what this returns zero we
already know because that's what it does
in our main so the next step would just
be to get these to work and well
you know make sure we're testing along
with our things the only thing we really
have is eat and a new a day so
um yeah that's that's really all we have
access to is
we can make our own values we can do eat
we can do new day we don't have any ways
to get anything here I was kind of
Designing a get total calories
um but this kind of needs to be outside
so what we can do is just go you know
we've got this nutritional total that
we're kind of working with privately so
we can just return it let me just go get
trying to think how to word this
get these calories so far
yeah sure
that's a little too descriptive get
total calories I just uh don't really
like having the same function named
twice here in a row just feels a little
awkward so I guess what we do is just
take this out
and just make its own function and it's
going to operate on this current run
values Dot
I'm just going to make sure to dot
values to get to this Vector kind of
just have it and collapsed in there
that might be unnecessary but yeah
I think it's fine for now
it kind of depends on how we're going to
move forward whether this makes sense or
not you know what I mean but uh that's a
bit of getting into Theory crafting
we're just trying to keep it simple
enough to uh get a little example here
just add it salt in here while we're at
it okay and we want to be be sure to
expose these in the head effects
essentially what makes people outside
our library able to know what they are
and use them all right and uh in our
main we want to be able we want to just
include our project now there's several
ways of doing this we can just pass or
we can add stuff to the C make the tell
the check directories but uh we're
probably just path here but first let's
just see if Visual Studio will pick this
up if we just try to uh instantiate some
values here
outside uh
sorry to see stuff we need we're gonna
need it actually and it looks like if we
right click on it it does know how to
find the headers so that's nice I would
hope so if it's in the same cmake
project but you never know it's kind of
an ID thing but if it doesn't you can
obviously just reference it you go back
a path and then down into the other one
and there we go we're able to have it in
our tester and we've got it linked now
this linking is very important on your
executable it's very important part of
understanding libraries is how to link
them to a main and this is just how you
just Target link libraries basically and
that's basically going to give it
whatever the rest of this Library built
into which is all these private
definitions they won't necessarily know
them because they're not recompiling
them they're just linking them in the
main okay so if we return calories it
should return zero as the default let's
see if it does that it does okay
all right and we're just going to add a
few more tests here because as we got it
and fix these now I think with the heat
we'll just confirm that the number is
bigger so
uh we need to pass in commands here
we'll pass in so it's going to call it
executable with this as the command
whereas the first ARG
I don't know what I'm clicking I'm
clicking the Json second org
so if the arc C is greater than one
let's process
the other one we'll just use string to
do this to keep it simplified and it's
at space one let's include string yeah
space one because zero is the first Arc
and the first Arc of course is you know
it it's the program name so the second
org is the first thing passed in which
is at space one
but Arc C should be counting also
starting from zero so that should be
right
and then we can just do some divs here
so we would just kind of run a test here
for an Heat
probably want to do a comprehensive test
we've got some test values up here
instantiated already I guess we could
use that so we could do stuff like well
we just want to create something like a
piece of food and set it to stuff so it
is just a struct let's say this food has
10 calories
and two salt and if we eat this food
we'll call eat on food we should have
now 10 calories and two Salt so we
should be able to
assert
well we don't actually want to do a cert
in this case we want a basically a
return value at the very end of if it's
good or bad so let's just declare that
return value
so we should see a 10 and a 2 right we
shouldn't be able to do some kind of
assertions here
um so we'll just do those with ifs if uh
food dot calories is not equal to well
we can
use our library here get total calories
because we've only eaten one piece of
food that's this one so it should be
equal to what we ate but if it's not
let's change this return value to
negative one
which will be a return false essentially
an error code
now we could check that with assault too
um
sure
could even do some I don't know we could
get clever and be like a minus equals
one it starts at zero
that would take it to negative one and
if it failed the salt one two would be
negative two just a theory and if it did
fail either should still be zero
assuming not equals it total assault the
same thing there
set this return value as maybe like a
kind of a bad odds
negative nine
negative 99 all right let's do that
because if it doesn't process the
command it should return a certain value
all right
so we can test a basic e what if we want
to eat multiple things because these are
accumulators we want to make sure it
accumulates so let's do a food too and
just eat both of them
go to our tests give it a run it passes
so we are good
you can step through this if you're
having weird errors if you want you just
right click and go to debug or well I
guess you need a break point I didn't
have a break point if you hit f11 it
breaks at your main and there we go so
you can break into these test codes as
well
just like you can any code this is
actually how you would access your
library a lot of times to your stressing
functions that only get called from the
client you would have to kind of debug
that way on your library
okay I think I've gone on long enough
with this episode hope you guys have
learned a thing or two about making
libraries and have enjoyed following
along if you have gotten this far I
would in uh you know let's say
congratulations first of all you're uh
you're killing it you're learning more
than most probably because this stuff
gets pretty complicated and you really
got to get into the Nitty Gritty to
understand it that's just the way it
goes
um but
you know I would challenge you to add a
second ARG if you're feeling like it
have this take more commands add more
tests because I'm going to push this to
GitHub and leave the link down below and
all that all right well I appreciate you
guys
um I'll see you in the next one peace